ethical fading is an established a
phenomenon in in in social science and
psychology um
uh it is the phenomenon where um people
make unethical decisions believing
they're well within their own ethical
framework
so for example
when a pharmaceutical company
that has a patent
on an essential drug
and they raise the price of that drug
300 percent 500 percent
thousand
800
two thousand percent
um to help them meet certain financial
targets
um not illegal
well kind of unethical right it doesn't
really feel good
or when wells fargo because they
exercise exerted so much financial
pressure on their employees
that
thousands of employees opened millions
of fake bank accounts some of which was
illegal
open millions of fake bank accounts
simply to help them make their sales
numbers
again
um in some cases that what they did
wasn't illegal but my goodness that's
unethical you know sending people credit
cards they didn't ask for and things
like that
um
uh uh and uh the amazing thing is is if
you you know especially like the
pharmaceutical companies you know we say
things like how can you sleep at night
they sleep just fine because they don't
think they did anything wrong and that's
ethical fading
um where they're making unethical
decisions unaware or at least able to
rationalize away so there's there's some
um indicators or or conditions
that exist that ethical fading starts to
take hold um
those include things like as i just said
rationalizing um
uh uh it's what my boss wants got to put
food on the table um everyone's doing it
my personal favorite it's the industry
standard
um right
uh
um that's that's part of it um that that
we we're creating we're using words
we're using language
rationalizing to em to a distance
ourselves from the impact of those
decisions right my boss wants it it's
really my boss it's the standard it's
it's not me that's making those
decisions it's the pressure i gotta do
it i gotta put food on the table right
we're creating distance we use other
language like euphemisms the overuse of
euphemisms like companies would never
spy on their customers data mining we
love however
right
[Music]
so we use words to again create
emotional distance
nobody talks about the impact that our
manufacturing process is happening on
the lives and the communities of the
places where we have our factories we
like to talk about managing
externalities right we use language to
create distance
the old slippery slope somebody tries it
gets away with it maybe even gets
rewarded for it does it again does it
again it gets bigger other people start
joining in and before you know it you
have full unethical fading
um
and and it is and it is it is a it is uh
it is pernicious when it takes hold and
every single time ethical fading happens
because of poor leadership
and it can be reversed because of good
leadership
um because we're rewarding
that kind of behavior we're exerting
excessive amounts of pressure on people
we're sometimes threatening them
if you miss your numbers you're going to
lose your job
right um
and and we create conditions in which
people um will do these things it almost
always starts and ends with the
leadership and the amazing thing is when
these people do these things like what
happened with wells fargo is they fired
all the people who did it
only because of public pressure was the
ceo eventually asked to leave but the
amazing thing is nobody thought maybe we
should fire the ceo
right who's the person who created the
environment in which this could happen
and just as we talked before about how
it's leadership that has to create the
environment which trust can thrive so
too does a leader create an environment
in which the opposite of trust thrives
which is this this ethical fading